[Music]
hi everyone
thanks for joining me i'm really excited
to be here i'm actually chatting with
you
from my apartment in cambridge
massachusetts
so it's a beautiful day here and i just
wanted to talk to you
a little bit about smartphones
and public health and the digital
frontier
and part of what i'm going to talk to
you about today is actually drawing from
my new book i'm a sociologist a writer
and an editor
and i recently uh published this book
that i'm showing you here on my screen
called the smartphone society technology
power and resistance in the new gilded
age
so thinking about our smartphones
actually this is an apt conversation in
part because
you might even be watching this talk on
your smartphone
but if we think about this very strange
moment
that we're in uh where millions perhaps
billions of us have been
sent indoors by this terrible pandemic
i think it's really highlighted for many
people
perhaps in a way that they weren't
quite aware of before what a deep
relationship they have
with their digital devices particularly
smartphones
and perhaps your relationship to your
smartphone
um has become even stronger
in the past couple months i think that
if we think about this relationship with
our digital devices
we might have mixed feelings so for
example
i think many of us could quickly come up
with some positive
dynamics that are occurring as a result
of our relationship with our smartphones
in the most basic sense
our smartphones are providing a really
crucial
source of information about this
horrible pandemic
but also just what types of strategies
our communities and governments are
implementing
to help quell the virus it's also
providing a really important lifeline to
loved ones and this is particularly
important for people who are struggling
with mental illness as a result
of social isolation or illnesses
that are being aggravated by social
isolation particularly the ld and
elderly
and those struggling with mental health
uh health
issues so we can think about that
and also just for the rest of us
particularly younger people
who are living alone our smartphones and
our digital connections are providing
much needed entertainment and
interaction
but at the same time we can also um
certainly think about some of the maybe
not so good things that are coming
uh with our increased reliance on our
digital
devices in particular if we think about
our
connection with our devices in terms of
information retrieval
certainly those who have a bit of a hard
time putting down their smartphones
might find themselves
more attached than ever to their digital
devices as we
helplessly scroll through the news feed
looking at the case count of our city
and our state and our country
um and really uh kind of falling into
these
news holes where we're just reading uh
you know
we already had this kind of 24-hour news
cycle but we
might find ourselves being sucked in
even worse uh than before
which uh might aggravate mental illness
uh force for some so if we think about
uh it could be good for some and and not
so good for
for others in terms of our addiction to
our smartphones
and we might also uh not necessarily
be retrieving accurate information or
getting a clear sense of
of what's actually happening around us
from the the types of
news articles and stories that we hear
you might have read recently
that approximately half of the
sort of traffic and accounts tweeting
about the coronavirus are likely
to be generated by bots so you're seeing
these threads and conversations
happening
on twitter about the coronavirus but
researchers at carnegie melligan
mellon suggest that about half of these
are are not
conversations that are coming from real
people
but today i'd like to talk to you about
a slightly different
way of of thinking about our devices
and also a sort of broader topic of
concern
which is this question of public health
and smartphones and in particular the
very rapid uptake
and implementation this is happening in
real time
of country by countries and companies
often working in sort of public private
partnerships around the world to
actually use our smartphones
as a way to quell the coronavirus
so i think that this is a pressing issue
not least because
it really highlights some of the
tensions between
privacy and public health and also
the tensions inherent in our
relationship with our digital devices
and the types of surveillance that could
be implemented
at this time you know in the name
of keeping us safe but
in a way that's not entirely clear and i
think that this is
one of the overwhelming kind of
dynamics that me me personally as i try
to get a clear picture
of what governments and companies around
the world
are doing in terms of using our
smartphones
and the data that we generate with them
in order to
create apps or enforce quarantines
and and implement a variety of measures
to
try to quell the virus outbreak
it's not uh it's not entirely clear
what actually is being done how our data
is being used
and and your average person
even you know community groups um
and and state governments are not really
a part of this conversation or allowing
for an
open conversation about what measures
we think are should be implemented and
what measures we're not so sure about
so if we think about some of the
strategies that
governments are using i put this slide
up here
dave gershkorn over at 1-0 made this
nice map
where he just said just a snapshot right
we say at least 30 countries are ramping
up
surveillance to combat the corona virus
and we see a wide variety of strategies
being implemented around the world so
one of the ways that our smartphones
are being used um is in
quarantine enforcement as i mentioned uh
just a minute ago
so if we think about a place like taiwan
they implemented an electronic fence
model
where your smartphone is essentially
acting
like an electronic ankle monitor for
people who are
under house arrest if you've been asked
to quarantine at home
in taiwan you are not allowed to
actually walk out of designated areas
which your phone will police and if your
phone uh
turns off for some reason um the police
will
pay you a visit uh to make sure that you
are still
in your apartment there was a story in
the newspaper about a student who
fell asleep and his phone died and he
woke up to the police at his door
because they wanted to see whether he
was actually
honoring home quarantine another
interesting
example of how phones are being used
was in poland people who were asked to
quarantine at home
for 14 days by their government were
required actually to check in
numerous times a day by
photographing themselves submitting a
selfie through an
app and if they didn't again the
local authorities would show up at the
door to make sure
that they were actually there and
honoring quarantine
these are just a couple different
examples we can also think
about how our smartphones are being used
in combination with broader data sets
to monitor how people are moving in
larger areas and what their access
should be
to public transportation businesses
grocery stores
and residential buildings one of the
most
elaborate systems was set up in china
in a partnership between china and
alibaba which is one of the biggest
tech companies in china and
what alibaba did was access
through its own databases and in
partnership with the chinese government
a whole uh you know multi-scaled
set of data where they created
city-by-city
algorithms to actually
police where individuals could go based
on where they lived and their own
personal history
so each person was required to download
um an app
and then at um whether they wanted to
enter the train station or enter the
grocery store or an apartment building
they would have to actually uh scan a qr
code on their phone
and only those with a green light were
allowed to proceed this was a city by
city system and it has been
um implemented in different ways it's
not a sort of
top-down you know uniform system
everywhere in china
but the system now is in place and even
though it's kind of
um been sort of scaled back
as the virus there has been quelled it
can quickly be called up
to be used later which is which is very
interesting
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas